dans le centre de nuit pro une imposante
synagogue adossé au menora center un
complexe créé il ya une dizaine d'années
on y trouve des salles de conférence des
restaurants casher des banques un musée
de la mémoire juive et de l'holocauste
un complexe devenu le coeur battant du
judaïsme dans la région en ces temps de
guerre sa synagogue est évidemment
devenu un lieu d'accueil cet homme a fui
kharkiv
nous avons été accueillis car nous
appartenons au peuple juif on essaye de
vivre ici pour le moment et réfléchir à
mettre à venir nous allons
vraisemblablement partir vers notre
patrie historique qui serait qu
beaucoup de femmes et d'enfants sont
partis depuis le début de la guerre mais
l'arrêt m'a envoyé sa femme et sa fille
en france
plus un pipeau m 20 % de ceux qui sont
restés sont des hommes ils ont envoyé
leur famille loin 10 yeux
nous venons ici chaque jour passé du
temps mais il nous entraider parce que
nos maisons sont vides
les sommes restés pris assidûment
igor à 90 ans et il a déjà connu la
guerre et l'exil
c'est la seconde guerre que je vis et à
mon âge je n'ai pas envie de partir
mais je pense que l'ukraine va gagner
même s'il y aura beaucoup de victimes et
de destructions
on va tout reconstruire et monsieur
poutine ne parviendra pas à obtenir et
chrétiens
la communauté juive en ukraine est
estimé à un noyau dur de quelques
dizaines de milliers de personnes mais
elle compterait jusqu'à 400 mille
individus selon le congrès juif européen
une communauté qui reste l'une des plus
importantes d'europe alors ici on
ironise lorsqu'on évoque le discours us
selon lequel vladimir poutine a lancé
une guerre contre les nazis ukrainien je
suis le nazillon chef c'est moi le
principal nazis qu'ils disent ce qu'ils
veulent ils n'ont plus rien à dire c'est
pour ça qu'il parle de nazis de fasciste
l'ukraine a toujours été le berceau de
la vie juive elle l'a toujours été il
n'y a jamais eu de nazis
à six heures de route de dnipro en
direction de l'ouest ou man cette petite
ville abrite la tombe du rabbin arman de
bresse l'ofs
elle attire des dizaines de milliers de
juifs hassidiques lors d'un pèlerinage
annuel
la guerre n'a pas empêché ce jeune new
yorkais de faire le voyage pour arriver
ici il est passé par la turquie puis la
moldavie
[Musique]
ici et intérêts le rabbin hartmann de
bresse l'oeuf qui nous a quitté il ya
plus de 200 ans nous sommes ses
disciples les notre inspiration nous
venons visiter sa tombe pour prier et
pour apprendre
le quartier juif ou la communauté
possède de nombreux hôtels et commerces
est quasi désert beaucoup d'habitants
sont partis pour israël
après le début de la guerre cette
synagogue a été ouverte aux déplacés et
à tous comme abric
le bâtiment abrite une des plus grandes
synagogues d'europe sur cinq niveaux
maintenant les relations entre les
ukrainiens et les juifs hassidiques sont
plus étroites qu'auparavant
ses assedic ont ouvert des hôtels
gratuitement pour pouvoir accueillir ces
ukrainiens qui arrivait et qui cherchait
sauver leur guise
adele fait partie de ceux qui sont
restés elle avait pour projet d'ouvrir
une petite épicerie dans le sous sol de
cet immeuble la guerre en a décidé
autrement elle prépare des repas pour
les déplacés qui fuient l'est du pays
je prépare presque tout même
dans chaque plat il y a une
particularité c'est qu'on y met notre
âme
il ya des gens qui viennent et qu'ils
baissent les yeux parce qu'ils sont
gênés de demander de l'aide
cette situation a mis tout le monde à
égalité
quelle que soit la nationalité ou la
religion
adele a hésité longtemps avant de rester
à oman elle avait préparé ses bagages
direction l'allemagne où israël avant de
se raviser
nous avons la terre-sainte d'israël
c'est notre devoir d'être ici maintenant
la guerre a provoqué l'exil d'une partie
de la communauté juive mais elle a
confirmé une tendance qui existe depuis
la révolution de maidan en 2014
l'appartenance à la religion juive n'est
aucunement un frein à une forme de
patriotisme ukrainien et beaucoup de
ceux qui sont partis espèrent bien
revenir
[Musique]